if you don't mind that you know
going back to the the crt critical
race theory can you can you take us back
with the history of this with
you know and i'm talking about how this
came about
freud karl marx frankfurt school antonio
gramski you know if you can go back and
break down how this whole thing came
about that in order for us to be able to
divide we need a revolution
and who came up with it and what's the
formula to make that happen
thank you there's two things i'm going
to mention the first
i want to go back to your point about
the tool of social media that we have
available
to us you'll you'll see in the news
right now that
the chinese communist party has just
celebrated
its 100 year anniversary of its creation
now for people that aren't familiar with
the history of the chinese communist
party i'll say
that go back a hundred years that's 1921
okay mao zedong
and a bunch of communist or marxist
revolutionaries
this is just several years after uh the
bolshevik revolution succeeded it's just
two years after communist party usa is
established
in the united states and communist
parties are established across
dozens and dozens of countries in the
world in the year and two following
the bolshevik revolution 1921
you have a communist party that's
established in china
but they did not notice have social
media available to them in 1921 and look
at the time
period involved in the revolutionary
efforts
that are slow growing like a cancer or a
metastasization
throughout rural china and getting a
uh proletariat base to rise up in
revolution against the incumbent
government
it's 1949 1949 nearly 30 years later
before a communist revolution
succeeds at pushing out nationals to to
the island of taiwan
with chiang kai-shek and other
nationalists and
and mao zedong establishes the chinese
communist party as a single party rule
within china
it's almost 30 years now you don't need
that kind of timeline
in modern america or in any modern
country that has social media to your
point
because the revolution and the ideas
of the revolution spread rapidly via
sound bites
to young vulnerable people uh who are
interested in getting
into the exciting romantic cause of
revolution
against the terrible oppressor so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye